en 2016 200 habitants du quartier du
valais boue ont participé à des ateliers
de co-création le but
imaginez 8 fresque murale on les a
écoutés et dans cette oeuvre là la toute
première celle qui parle de la poésie
ils nous ont parlé d'un certain nombre
de mythes urbains d'expérience de
couleurs de cultures qui font leur
richesse
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a une grande
diversité de couleurs qui correspond
souvent à toute la diversité des
cultures qui font la richesse du valais
vous près de 50 cultures différentes
sont présentes sur le quartier et nous
sommes allés chercher aussi dans les
anecdotes de chaque culture pour parler
notamment de l'oiseau lyre qui est
l'oiseau de la poésie du moyen-orient il
ya un clin d'oeil aux fables de la
fontaine et depuis le début du mois
d'avril la première fresque murale prend
forme ses créations sont financés à
hauteur de 170 mille euros par le
bailleur les résidences yvelines essonne
le quartier est réhabilité en trois
tranches on en est à la deuxième et donc
que ces résidences qui s'occupe des
travaux de réhabilitation du quartier
mais avec madame le maire nous étions
très intéressé pour reproduire ce qu'on
a vu dans d'autres villes comme à lyon
ou à chartres c'est à dire associer les
habitants à la construction de fresques
qui représente finalement leur vie
locale leur quartier leur immeuble et
qu'il raconte un petit peu leur histoire
est qu'il devienne fiers de leur
quartier maintenant donc pleinement
réhabilité le bailleur devrait démarrer
la réhabilitation de la troisième
tranche de logements à la fin de l'année
2017 début 2018
au total huit fresque seront visibles et
orneront les murs du quartier du val
hibou en 2020